(acclamations)
- Ils étaient une dizaine
ce matin devant les locaux
du Chaînon, à Montréal, pour
encourager Caroline Paradis.
Cette mère de famille s'est
lancé un défi de taille : faire
le tour du Québec, seule à vélo,
pour aider les femmes en
difficulté, pour leur donner
la force de croire en elles.
CAROLINE PARADIS, instigatrice
du défi Caro à vélo
- Le défi Caro à Vélo
a pour mission aussi d'amasser
des fonds pour soutenir
Le Chaînon, ici à Montréal,
mais j'ai comme objectif
également de faire rayonner
toutes les maisons d'hébergement
que je vais croiser
sur ma route.
- Le défi Caro à vélo, c'est
un trajet de 4400 km à travers
la province, qui passera par la
Capitale-nationale, la Gaspésie,
la Côte-Nord, le Saguenay-
Lac-Saint-Jean et même
la Baie-James. Un exploit
qu'elle compte réaliser
en 40 jours.
- Mon idée première avec le défi
Caro à vélo, c'est de parler de
courage puis d'utiliser le défi
sportif en parallèle aussi
avec les défis que les femmes
qui vivent de la violence
psychologique ou physique,
ou autres problèmes dans la vie,
ont à déployer au quotidien.
- Le parcours qui l'attend
l'enthousiasme, mais suscite
aussi quelques appréhensions
parce qu'un tel trajet,
c'est une première pour elle.
- Moi, de partir comme ça,
toute seule aussi, ça me brasse
à l'intérieur. Je peux avoir
beaucoup de peurs. Je suis
quelqu'un d'ordinaire.
Je ne suis pas une athlète.
- Pour les femmes hébergées au
Chaînon, qui ont tenu à saluer
Caroline avant son départ,
le soutien qu'elle leur offre
est précieux.
- C'est sûr que c'est important
pour nous parce que s'il n'y a
pas d'argent, il n'y a pas de
maison comme ça. On se retrouve
à la rue, on ne sait pas
où aller. On a besoin
du monde comme ça.
- C'est pas facile la situation
qu'on vit puis je trouve ça
extraordinaire qu'elle fasse ça,
là, pour nous, là.
- (en choeur): Trois, deux...
- Le long périple de Caroline
Paradis s'est amorcé ce matin
avec ses proches, qui sont déjà
impatients de la retrouver
au même endroit à la mi-juin.
Ici Aimée Lemieux,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.